we're talking in money watch about how
to protect yourself and your job in
uncertain Economic Times this week's
Facebook uh parent company meta
announced plans to lay off another 10
000 employees after cutting 11 000 jobs
back in November it is just one of the
many tech companies reducing their
Workforce this year this along with the
Silicon Valley Bank collapse in high
inflation as many Americans on edge and
you just heard that introduction she
needs no introductions news business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is back with
what you need to know dollar dollar Jill
what's up good morning I know I'm sure
we're laughing because this is like
pretty serious people are losing their
jobs yes I don't want people to freak
out no so that's the question we have
for you what should people know about
the state of the economy right now when
they see numbers like that when they see
the collapse of that bank and there
perhaps will be others what do you want
them to be focused on I think the most
important thing is that actually the
economy is doing okay right now and we
hear a lot of layoffs in the technology
sector certainly layoffs in the media
sector but
but the job situation remains pretty
good if we look at last month 311
000 jobs created we're very deep into
our recovery the unemployment rate is at
3.6 percent it's pretty close to these
50-year lows and we also look back say
six months an average job creation for
the last six months over 340 000 jobs a
month this is a market in terms of the
labor market and an economy that
continues to produce jobs that said I
hate to be a buzz kill Jill because I
play one on TV when things are good
that's when I actually want to talk
about what you should be thinking about
in case you're worried about a layoff
well before we get to layoffs let's talk
about you have a job and you want more
money for that job in your book great
money reset you talk about being an
advocate for yourself at work I want to
talk about quiet quitters in a second
also but for for people looking for that
raise how should they go about getting
it I think what's most most important
when we look at our careers is to
understand that we have power it's not
unlimited power but we have to be able
to have conversations with the people
who we work with and for so before you
book this conversation though you want
to do some homework and you really have
to button up what you're asking for and
I think this is incredibly important
people want different things so do I
want more Flex time do I want to raise
do I want uh do I want vacation and then
I really want to understand what's going
on at my company because if I work at
meta right now and I go in and ask for a
raise they're going to look at me like
you're nuts Jill right so you understand
the landscape of the company you have to
practice your pitch you really should
and I think this is good to have a
friend that you can just say hey Vlad
let's run through this let me look at
this and you also want to make sure you
don't act like a jerk you want to lose
the ego even if you're in a business
that really does value what you're doing
don't be that person who pounds the a
desk don't make ultimatums and please do
not burn Bridges life is short and
people move around quite a bit but you
have to open the conversation I remember
I had a short stint in finance and I
remember we were we were literally
taught that men were more likely to go
into the office and ask for that raise
than women and that was part of why men
are paid more because they're opening
their mouths so it's really this is such
good advice quiet quitting though we got
to talk about quiet quitting this is
like this idea of people who are really
losing engagement in their in their jobs
doing the bare minimum I imagine this is
not a time for that yes I mean look
I sound like old Aunt Jill saying there
is no such thing as work-life balance
however I think at a time where the
economy is becoming a lot more uncertain
and we see layoffs that are starting to
spread into other sectors now might be
the time where I actually get more
engaged where I raise my hand and I ask
for more of the responsibility it's a
weird thing how quickly things can turn
to go back in time you can say just a
year and a half ago employers and
employees had a really different view of
what was going on employees had a lot of
power now that's shifting and things can
turn very quickly so please don't go
sort of on your back feet it's action
time not passivity time you're going to
quit quit loud get out there I own eight
pound the table that's good advice Jill
thank you so much and